the faa and fbi are investigating a
startling report of what they're calling
an aerospace
intruder a man wearing a jet pack
the faa says two airline crews reported
the close encounter sunday night
approaching los angeles international
airport
chris van cleave is following the
investigation for us chris good morning
to you
what do we know well good morning
investigators are skeptical it was in
fact a jet pack but
talk about a high flying mystery in the
skies over los angeles
did two pilots really see a man with a
jet pack
at three thousand feet that's our
american 1997 we just passed the guy in
a jet pack
then another jet pack sighting moments
later from a southwest pilot
[Applause]
jet packs like this one from l.a based
jetpack aviation are not common
only a handful of companies in the world
make them and they are not commercially
available
the company says their technology was
not involved
jet pack aviation ceo confirmed to cbs
news he has been in touch with the faa
about the technology but says their
aircraft does not have enough fuel
to get a person to 3000 feet and back to
the ground safely
adding they are loud so it seems
unlikely no one on the ground
would notice it taking off flying or
landing and then there's this from the
air traffic controller
23 he's captain person in the jet pack
reported
300 yards south of the la final at about
three thousand feet
tables
only in l.a only in l.a for sure now
investigators do believe the pilots saw
something they're just not sure it was a
jet pack the fact that there is no video
that surfaced from the ground
also makes them skeptical but just what
it is remains a mystery
gail all right thank you chris vancleep
i think it's interesting guys it remains
a
mystery if two pilots saw it i could see
it maybe one
but two pilots saw it why no one on the
ground seeing it that's the question
i don't know can you imagine if you're
sitting in your seat chilling and you
look out the window and there's a guy
got a jet pack one of those things your
eye you think your eyes are deceiving
you but that's scary that is very scary
stuff